avec le docteur malick à romano médecin
au centre de planification de dijon et
aussonne alors avant pour être clair
c'était toute une aventure pour avoir
accès en torno aujourd'hui en deux clics
quand on le veuille ou qu'on ne veuille
pas on l'a tous vécu on peut arriver sur
un contenu porno et je lui disais tout à
l'heure on va pas rêver nos enfants ne
sont pas des anges
et là il ya danger malika oui alors nos
enfants ne sont pas des anges en effet
en même temps ils ont été équipées de
téléphone et de l'ordinateur ce qui les
aident effectivement avant si on voulait
regarder de la pornographie va les faire
une démarche active allié à un vidéo
club aux choses comme cela
en effet maintenant avec n'importe quel
écran c'est facile de se connecter
on l'a voulu ou pas en effet et les
gamins c'est pareil des fois ils ont
décidé d'aller regarder la plante en
graphie tout seul ou en groupe et
d'autres fois ils regardent autre chose
et bm un spam arrivent avec des images
qui peuvent les chopines d'autant plus
qu'ils n'ont pas choisi de regarder
quelles sont ses conséquences sur nos
enfants comment parler à nos enfants nos
petits enfants de par nos ou de
sexualité on va faire le point en ce
sens mais d'abord pour bien comprendre
le porno et les jeunes aujourd'hui ça
ressemble à quoi on vous emmener
quelques images rassurez vous on peut
tous les voir à cette heure-ci regardais
je suis sûr que thomas regarde des films
pornos on a tous fait ça à son âge peut
être mais le souci ce que nos enfants on
taxait de plus en plus tôt au porno
aujourd'hui la moitié des ados entre 15
et 17 ans déclarent avoir déjà surfé sur
des sites pornographiques
ils étaient seulement 37 % en 2013 et
quand on commence on ne s'arrête pas 21%
des jeunes de 14 à 24 ans en consomment
au moins une fois par semaine
le problème c'est que le porno offre une
image de la sexualité qui n'est pas réel
il valorise la performance et mais
souvent la femme dans une situation de
soumission et dégradantes
inquiétant quand on sait que 44% des
adam tente de reproduire les scènes
qu'ils ont vu et même catastrophique
quand ces scènes sont vus par de jeunes
enfants
ils peuvent être durablement perturbée
sachez qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
smartphone qui est le plus utilisé pour
regarder les films x
mes parents pas de panique comme sur
l'ordinateur vous pouvez installer des
logiciels de contrôle parental et dites
vous qu à partir de 12 13 ans il est
normal de s'intéresser à la sexualité
parlez-en avec eux ne vous immiscer pas
dans leur intimité mais faites leur
comprendre que le porno c'est pas la
norme
dr malick à romano une réaction je
trouve que c'est bien fait c'est assez
représentatif en effet nous ce qui nous
pose problème c'est que les gamins qui
ont été soumis à des images ils
n'oseront pas forcément parler un adulte
de référence parents ou pas parce qu'il
culpabilise ils se rendent compte qu'ils
ont peut-être fait quelque chose qu'il
n'avait pas à faire
du coup ils ont tendance à se taire à
garder ça pour eux à être mal parfois
parce qu'ils sont choqués ou interloqué
et ça peut être ôté dans leur tête un
moment avant qu'ils arrivent d'une façon
ou d'une autre à pouvoir en parler ou à
le faire comprendre
alors si cette europe un petit peu dans
leur tête j'imagine qu'il ya des signes
pour nous parents grands-parents à quel
moment doit commencer peut-être alors
papa certainement tout cas se poser des
questions et se dire tiens mon fils m'a
fait mon petit fils ma petite fille
peut-être faire un tour sur ces sites
pornographiques c'est difficile de
répondre à cette question parce que ça
dépend de l'âge je pense qu'à 14 15 ans
ça va les amuser ça peut les choquer
mais il ya un côté allait enfin
curiosité de filles entre copains cas là
c'est une source l'information de
sexualité faut le reconnaître c'est
déplorable mais il faut partir de ce
postulat là à 8 ans c'est complètement
autre chose à 8 ans quand ils ont été
exposés
si ça s'est répétée au même s'ils ont
été choqués peut-être se mettre à mal
dormir à moins manger enfin les signes
classiques d'un enfant qui va pas trop
as prostré dans sa chambre pas trop
vouloir sortir enfin à éluder à fuir
peut-être alors que toujours là nous les
parents que nous sommes le ou les grands
parents
on se pose la question de la
responsabilité
on n'est pas tous à même de pouvoir
parler sexualité avec ses parents et ses
enfants parce que on peut avoir un
blocage soit même pour diverses raisons
que les conseils que vous puissiez
donner aux parents et aux grands parents
qui sont avec nous ce matin pour essayer
de faire en sorte qu'ils puissent en
parler à leurs enfants
s'il y arrive tant mieux ce qui est
compliqué dans le fait de parler de
sexualité c'est que ça renvoie à notre
propre sexualité
sommes nous à l'aise etc et même si
parler à l'autre en particulier à
l'enfant de sexualité n'est pas parler
de nos sexualités
mais de façon générale il faut parler de
l'intimité du respect du consentement
des grandes notions comme ça en fonction
de l'âge de l'enfant lui dire que
évidemment la pornographie n'est
absolument pas représentatif de la
bisexuelle qu'il ya des effets spéciaux
qu'il ya des façons de films etc et que
on n'attend pas de la performance dans
l'amour dans le sexe qu'est ce que veut
dire et tout ça pour dire que toutes les
images que l'on peut voir en matière de
pornographie ce sont bien souvent des
images fortes qui existent mais elles
peuvent être tronquée parce que vous
lisiez fort justement les hommes sur
surdimensionné oms reste caché voilà dur
excellent à l'aller les femmes c'est
ceci cela ben voilà c'est pas la vraie
vie c'est pas la marée sexualité et
c'est ça qui me pose problème
est ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
si on ne se sent pas en capacité en tant
que parents grands parents de parler à
ses enfants de sa ce qui est normal il
faut pas hésiter à s'adresser à des gens
qui peuvent leur en parler avec un peu
de distance de la neutralité parce
qu'ils ne seront pas impactés
affectivement émotionnellement nous on
peut recevoir nous médecins conseillers
conjugaux des jeunes avec ou sans leurs
parents ou simplement les parents pour
essayer de les aiguiller quoi les grands
parents s'il peut bien leur foi joue un
rôle moi je m'en sors je sais pas pour
vous le rend pour vous dominique mais
moi ma génération c'était la boue
avec sophie marceau avec vic avec
puppets hammami c'était de discret à
l'été bah oui et quand même et elle
était typiquement à fond sur le quai des
grands parents qui nous regardent et qui
parfois peuvent peut-être joué par les
arbitres cg pas d'arbitrer un match on
n'est pas sur la coupe du monde de rugby
des enfants mais malgré tout peuvent
peut-être essayer de faire le tampon
c'est pas facile parfois de parler à
papa ou maman mais peut-être plus facile
à ma myopie pleuve est les personnes de
référence que les gamins ont choisi
justement les embryons seconde manche
pas trop bien je sais pas dominique
enfin le plus jeune de mes enfants à 32
ans donc cette génération donc c'est la
dépression si cette génération là elle
est passée dans une zone encore un peu
un peu contrôlable voilà ouais j'ai à
dire un peu molle ce qu'on dit mais
c'est plutôt pour les les petits enfants
le il arrive dans une des bap et gérer
observé aussi qu' on n'est même plus
dans le porno professionnel aujourd'hui
c'est l'exhibitionnisme de 2 to le
monsieur tout le monde aussi madame tout
le monde qui vont cramant et s'affiche
alors là je crois que c'est encore plus
désastreux que qu'un concept loup un
contexte de le pornographie
professionnel et c'est surtout avant
c'était contrôlé et l'accès parce que au
cinéma pornographique il fallait montrer
quel âge dans la tête ça fait maintenant
il ya n'importe qui peut se fumer ça
fait des contenus de plus en plus trash
gore est de plus en plus violent parce
que par rapport à ce qui deviendrait
addict il faut aller toujours plus fort
plus loin plus en plus dans la violence
et à savoir qu' effectivement comme sont
des sites plus les gens consultent plus
il récupère de l'argent donc c'est la
surenchère de celui qui devra être le
plus interactions vous avez la parole ça
se passe au 0 805 383 383 je vous
propose d'écouter le témoignage de
christian bonjour je suis le papa d'un
petit garçon de 11 ans
qui est très souvent sur son ordinateur
on est très peu occupé par les images
pornographiques qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux
on a mis quelques règles en place à la
maison pour éviter qu'ils puissent être
confronté à ce type de document la porte
de la chambre ouverte
pas d'ordinateur au coucher le contrôle
parental mais est ce suffisant
de plus lorsqu'il est à l'école avec ses
copains en récréation sur leur
smartphone qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
regarder on ne peut rien contrôler voilà
je cherche quelques solutions que je
pourrais mettre en oeuvre pour éviter
qu'ils soient confrontés à ce genre
d'image c'est bien trop tôt par rapport
à son âge voilà merci merci à vous
christian ce papa qui est
particulièrement inquiet on l'a entendu
il est papa d'un enfant de 11 ans on se
reconnaît un peu tout cela maintenant
aujourd'hui ainsi c'est pas les enfants
c'est les petits enfants le conseil que
vous puissiez donner même si on l'a bien
compris a pas de miracles aujourd'hui
vous le disait fort justement on vit à
l'heure de l'internet illimité les
robinets sont ouverts est temps qu'ils
rentrent pas quelqu'un qui régule la
serbie ne sera pas possible idéalement
faudrait que les sikhs n'existe plus
mais ça n'est pas possible ça change
beaucoup ce ne sont pas français bien
sûr donc ils ont contrôlé même que les
fournisseurs d'accès à internet en
vivent essentiellement aux 6 12 heures
il faut pas tuer la poule e je pense que
c'est enfin je le rejoins totalement
c'est hyper important de se soucier de
se questionner de mettre des règles à la
maison je pense que pour l'enfant ça lui
signifie aussi que oui il ya des choses
qu'on ne peut pas regarder et que les
parents sont vigilants effectivement
avec les amis tout est accessible
je pense que c'est important de rester
vraiment à la disposition de son enfant
et de lui dire n'hésitent pas à venir
m'en parler tu n'as pas à culpabiliser
si tu as vu des choses qu'on t'a montré
des images qui touche ok je suis là pour
en parler ou je saurai écouter et
adresser à quelqu'un de spécialisé
docteur malick à romano il ya la célèbre
question finalement la sexualité ça
commence par ça c'est dit papa dit maman
comment on fait les enfants ça commence
par là la sexualité
il faut vraiment en s'informer la
sexualité des personnes arrivent au
moment où il naît sans fin on a un sexe
est aussi une partie anatomique et un
enfant qui a trois quatre ans bah oui il
va il va se toucher à certains
depuis dix ans c'est rigolo ça me fait
des guilis bas il va dire effectivement
alors ça n'est pas sexualisé pour lui il
n'a pas de contenu érotique ou
pornographique à ce moment là néanmoins
il a compris que c'était une zone de son
corps à ces faits ni guy quoi mais c'est
agréable
donc ça peut être deux à ce moment-là
dire mon écoute ça ça te regarde c'est
pas interdit
thual roth toucher à cet endroit là au
niveau du sexe mais tu fais ça quand tu
es tranquille
moi ça m'intéresse pas de voir ça donc
c'est aussi mettre des limites et c'est
aussi répondre à ses enfants ça veut
dire que si on ne répond pas ses enfants
si on laisse certains gamins us voilà un
gamin sans réponse pas forcément on l'a
tous et je le disais ma rage on n'est
pas des anges
1 voilà on repasse le cas chez nos
enfants ne sont pas des gens nous ne
sommes pas des anges non plus et si on
nous laisse sans réponse eh bien on va
chercher
donc il vaut mieux discuter regarder la
communication qu'il ya un enfant comment
on fait un bébé bas avec ce qu'il peut
entendre un langage adapté
il ya l'image la garenne favon etc qui
évolue avec le temps et après faut dire
les choses sans être cru mais je crois
que nos mails et les parties anatomiques
du corps ça répond aux questions de
l'enfant et l'arrêtent de fantasmer sur
quelque chose d'incroyable et je crois
qu'il faut y aller il faut pas leur en
creuse et vous qui est inspecteur de
l'éducation nationale je voyais écouter
j'imagine que vous avez forcément vous
sur le terrain des des enfants des
enseignants aussi qui parfois vous
appelle en vous disant ou là des choses
qui sont pas très normal là dans la
classe ce que vous disiez d'acteurs
paraît essentiel c'est effectivement que
les enfants et la possibilité s'exprimer
et s'il ya un lieu où ils peuvent
s'exprimer c'est à l'école et les
enseignants qui sont habitués à être
attentifs peuvent parfois allumer la
lumière pointé le problème il ya des
enfants qui sont en danger
heureusement un petit nombre mais c'est
toujours beaucoup de trop et oui vous
allez chez nous des deux trois années
que j'ai passé ma circonscription il ya
des directeurs d'école qui m'ont parfois
appelée pour me dire la clause qui m'a
pas là il faut à terme et d'autres
fables et